ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้ครับนักเรียนสวัสดี
ครับนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สาวผมนะกลับมากลับมาเรียนภาษาไทยกับครัว
ตีเป็นภาษาไทยกับน้องเตรียมน้องเอ็มอยู่
ด้านไหนอยู่นี่คือท่านนี้
โอเควันนี้วันนี้เรามาเรียนภาษาไทยกันนะ
ครับวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันนี้ไม่รู้นี่
ที่ 1
ว้าววันที่ 1 โห
[เพลง]
ถ้าไม่ใช่ครับวันนี้ก็แค่หนึ่งไม่ใช่
วันนี้เดือน
เดือนนี้เดือนธันวาคมเดือน
ธันวาคมมาไม่ใช่พฤศจิกายนไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่
เดือนนี้
ธันวาคมห้าใช่ครับใช่ค่ะขอให้คมปีคศอะไร
ครับปีคศ
2010  21
K100  21 แล้วปีพตอะไรครับเอพสไตส์
อ่าโอเคพ.ศ
2560  4 แล้วตอนนี้ครับตอนนี้ที่เรา
กำลังจะเรียนภาษาไทยกันกี่โมงแล้วครับตอน
โอ้นี่ใช่ขายโมง 45 นตอนนี้บายโมง
45 นาทีใช่ไหมใช่ 5 นาทีโหโอเควันนี้วัน
นี้น้องเรียมมีอะไรจะมามาคุยกับนักเรียน
ครับวันนี้เราคุยกันเรื่องนี้
เราจะคุยกันเรื่อง
นี้ๆครับอ่าแบนอ่าในรูปนี้ก่อนในรูปนี้หา
น้องเรียมเห็นอะไรบ้างครับในรูปนี่
เตรียมเห็นลูกบอล 5 มีรูปพรหานี่ลูกบอลสี
เขียวใช่ไหมลูกบอลกลมกลมลมอีกเป็นลูกบอล
กลมน้าน้าสีเขียวลบ
ตัวกลมกลมสีเขียวว้าวหน้าแล้วเห็นอะไรอีก
ครับ
เตรียมเห็นกล่อง
กล่องสีน้ำตาลอ้ากล่องอันนี้นี่น่านี่
เป็นกลองใช่ไหมเป็นกล่อง
5 กล่อง
กล่องสี่เหลี่ยมใช่ไหมครับสี่เหลี่ยมนาย 5
สิสีอะไรนะครับสีอะไรอยู่นะไม่ตาล
สีน้ำตาลอ่านี่สีน้ำตาลว้าวมีวงกลมอ่าลูก
บอลกลมกลมๆอยู่บน
บนกล่องเสียงตาลใช่ไหมน๊าค่ะวันกล่องสี
น้ำตาลโอเคโอเคมีลูกบอลกลมสีเขียวขับขี่
ลูกค่ะอ่ะเหรียญ 5 มีกี่ลูกใช่ไหมอ่ะมี
ลูกบอลสีเขียว 2 ลูกหน้านี่หนึ่งลูกสอง
ลูกมีลูกบอลสีเขียว 2 ลูกครับ
แล้วมีกล่องสีน้ำตาล
กี่กล่องค่ะมิกล่องสีน้ำตาล 2 กล่องนี่ 1
กล่อง 2 บอกชายมีกล่องสีน้ำตาล 2 กล่อง
น้ำมีลูกบอลสีเขียว 2 ลูกหน้าไซ้ครับ
แต่ว่าอีกรูปนึง
ลูกบอลกลมสีเขียวอยู่บน
กล้ารุ่นนี้อยู่บนใต้ครับ
แต่อีกแล้วนึงลูกอีกลูกบอลสีเขียว
อยู่ด้านล่างเอาชัย
อยากได้กล่องหน้า 5 อยู่ใต้กล่องให้ทำ
หน้ามันใต้เกาะกล่องกล่องนี้กล่องสีน้ำ
ตาลอยู่บนบนลูกบอลหน้าตอนนี้นะครับน้า
อ่อนหานี้อยู่บนตอนนี้อันนี้อยู่ที่ไหน
ครับต้องอยู่ที่ไหนครับอยู่ใต้อ้าอยู่ใต้
ลูกบอลสีเขียวต้องหน้าตอนนี้ลูกบอลอยู่
ใต้กรอบหน้าอันนี้ลูกบอลอยู่บนกล่องกล่อง
5 ใส่งับมีกรอบอยู่บนโอเค
นะครับหน้าเดี๋ยวเดี๋ยวอ่ะไปดูภาพถัดไป
ครับ
นี้ภาพนี้ภาพนี้คะอ่ามีอะไรอยู่ในภาพนี้
บ้างครับอ่า
ตั้งโต๊ะ
หน้ามีโต๊ะหน้านี้ครับโต๊ะ
หน้าแล้วมีอะไรอีกครับมีเด็กผู้หญิง
เด็กผู้หญิงเด็กผู้หญิงอยู่นี่ตรงนี้เด็ก
ผู้หญิงทำอะไรอยู่ครับ
เด็กผู้หญิงกำลังนั่งอ้ากำลังนั่งใช่ครับ
ขอดาวเด็กผู้หญิงนั่งอยู่นั่งอยู่ที่ไหน
ครับ
เด็กคนโต๊ะหรือขึ้นอยู่
[เพลง]
ใต้โต๊ะนั่งใต้โต๊ะได้ไหมครับ
โอเคอ้าแล้วภาพนี้ภาพนี้เด็กผู้หญิงเด็ก
ผู้หญิงทำอะไรอยู่ครับเด็กผู้หญิงนั่ง
อยู่นั่งอยู่โอ้โห
นั่งอยู่บนโต๊ะได้ไหมครับ 5 นั่งอยู่บน
โต๊ะม้านั่งให้คนตบ
โบกมือ
ฮ่าๆๆฮัลโหลโหลสวัสดีครับอยู่นี่นั่งอยู่
นี่ใช่ไหม
อ๋อโอเคโอเค
มา
เด็กผู้หญิงฮ้อ up
โหใส่เสื้อสีฟ้า
ใช่ใส่เสื้อสีฟ้า
เป็นเสื้อแขนสั้นใช่ไหมเสื้อใช่ 5 เพื่อ
ตี้วันนี้เพียงตีก็ใส่เสื้อแขนสั้นเหมือน
กัน
เรียงไม่ได้ใส่เสื้อแขนสั้นก็ขอเพียงใส่
เสื้อแขนยาว
เนื้อหาเสื้อแขนยาวหน้าเด็กผู้หญิงเอกผู้
หญิง
ไม่ได้ใส่เสื้อแขนยาวเด็กผู้หญิงใส่เสื้อ
แขนสั้นอ่ะ
แม่หน้าต่อไปครับเดี๋ยวเราไปดูภาพต่อไป
ต่อไปภาพต่อไปนี่ครับน้าในภาพนี้ภาพนี้มี
อะไรน้องเรียมเห็นอะไรอยู่ในภาพนี้บ้าง
ครับเรียงเห็น
แมว
แมวหน้าตัวนี้ใช่ไหมครับนี่แมวห่าใจค่ะ
แมวแมวกำลังทำอะไรอยู่ครับ
แนวกำลังนั่งอ้าแมวนั่งอยู่ใช่ไหมครับอ่า
โอเคไทยคะเตรียมก็
นั่งอยู่อ๋ออ๋อนั่งอยู่ตีเพียงดี
ก่อนนะก็เหมือนกันหานั่งอยู่บนเก้าอี้ 17
ที่มีเก้าอี้
นั่งอยู่บนเก้าอี้นะครับโอเคโอเคแมวนั่ง
อยู่แล้วตรงนี้ตรงนี้อะไรครับกล่อง
หากล่องใช่ไหมอ่ามีกล่องแล้วก็มีแมวหน้า
แมวตัวนี้นั่งอยู่ที่ไหนครับ
แมวนั่งอยู่
นอกกล่องอ๋ออยู่นอกนอกกล่องใช่ไหมครับใช่
เขาโอเคมีนั่งอยู่นอกเกาะ
แล้วอ่ะตรงนี้ล่ะครับภาพนี้ภาพนี้
หาเรียงเห็นข้างๆแมว
นั่งอยู่ไหนขอโทรศัพท์แมว
ที่นั่งอยู่ในกล่อง
อ๋ออยู่ในกล่องได้ไหมอ่าแมวนั่งอยู่แต่
ไม่ได้อยู่ไม่ได้อยู่นอกไม่ได้อยู่นอก
กรอบอยู่ในกล่องหรออ๋อโอเคแมวนั่งอยู่ใน
กล่อง
โอเคในกล่องในกล่องมีแมวกี่ตัวครับ
ในกล่องมีแมว 1 ตัวอ๋ออ๋อมีแมว 1 ตัวใน
กล่อง
ใครเข้าแล้วแมวแมวอยู่นอกกล่องอีตัวครับ
แนวอยู่นอกหล่องๆ your  5 อยู่นอกกล่อง 1
ตัวตัวนี้
1 ตัวอยู่ออกนอกกรอบ
แค่โอเคไปดูภาพต่อไป
นี่ภาพนี้ครับ
555 น้องเรียมเห็นอะไรในเกียรติเห็นบ้าน
หมอมีบ้านนี่บ้านว้าวบ้าน
หาบ้านนี้บ้านนี้มีอะไรอยู่ที่บ้านนี้
บ้างครับมีประตูก็
หาใช่นี่ประตูนะครับ 5 เป็นประตูเคปิด
ประตูแล้วมีอะไรอีกครับมีหน้าต่าง
หน้าต่าง
หน้าต่างอยู่ตรงไหนครับ
ตรงนี้ตรงนี้ก็ตรงนี้เสียงครับ
หน้าหน้า
ก็อ่าอ๋ออ๋อหน้าต่างอะมีประตู
มีหน้าต่างหน้าต่างอยู่หลังคา
ถ้ามีหลังคาหลังคาคืออันนี้ใช่ไหมครับนี่
หลังคา
หาหลังคาโอเคมี
กล่องไฟอ้าตรงนี้ลองไฟใช่มั้ยฮะอ่ามี
ปล่องไฟนี่
โอเคปล่องไฟอ่าครับใช่เขามีเบียร์ตีเห็น
เห็นมีผู้หญิงมีผู้หญิงอยู่คนนึงนี่เนี่ย
5 ผู้หญิงคนนี้ครับเตรียมก็เห็นอ่ะ
เห็นผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงหาผู้หญิงนายสมชายครับในบ้านขอผู้
หญิงอยู่ในในบ้าน 5 ได้ครับผู้หญิงคนนี้
อยู่ในบ้านหน้า
แล็ปรูปรูปข้างๆ
รูปข้างๆข้างๆแค่รูปข้างๆนะมีบ้านเหมือน
กันใช่มั้ยใช่ว่าบ้านกันโอเคครับ
แล้วก็มีผู้หญิงอ้าผู้หญิงตอนนี้งูหญิง
นอกบ้านขออยู่นอกบ้านอยู่นอกบ้านแล้ว 5
รูปนี้อยู่ในบ้านรูปนี้อยู่นอกบ้านหน้า
โอเค
หน้ามีในบ้านและนอกบ้านใช่ไหมล่ะปีที่อา
ตี้อยู่ในบ้านหรือนอกบ้าน
ฮ่าๆๆอันนี้พี่อาร์ตี้อยู่ในบ้านอยู่ไหน
บ้านใช่ครับหน้าหอแล้วน้องเรียวโรงเรียน
หญิงในบ้านหรือนอกบ้านครับ
เรียงอยู่ในบ้านอ๋ออ๋อในบ้าน 5 เพื่อตีก็
อยู่ในบ้านเปียตี้คิดว่านักเรียนนักเรียน
ก็อยู่ในบ้าน
5 นะคะนักเรียนอยู่ในบ้านหรือ
อยู่นอกบ้านอยู่ในบ้านหรืออยู่นอกบ้าน
ครับ
โอเคอ้าเดี๋ยวเราไปรูปต่อไปรูปต่อไป
อาเจ้
นี่
ว่าเศร้า
มีอะไรอยู่ไหนรูปมีบ้างครับเรียงเห็นแมว
แมวแมวอยู่นี่แม่แมวาอ่าใช่แล้วแมวตัวสี
อะไรครับเนี่ยแมวสีดำ
ค้อข้อสีดำ
และสีขาว
และสีขาวอ๋อมีสีดำและสีขาวอ้าแมวมี 2 สี
ใช่ไหมครับมีสีดำ
สีดำ
และสีขาว
น้า
หน้าสีดำและสีขาวรวมกันอ่ะทรายราคารวมกัน
พี่แมวมี 2 สี
มี 2  4 สี
หาโอเคแล้วแมวมีแมวแล้วมีอะไรอีกครับนี่
สีน้ำตาลสีน้ำกล่องอ๋ออ๋อมีแมวแล้วก็มี
กล้องอ๋อโอเค
หน้ากล้องแมวตาล
กล่องสีน้ำตาลนะครับ
แมวอยู่ที่ไหนครับ
แมวอยู่ในกล่องอยู่ในกล่องมีอ่ะมีแมวอยู่
ในกล่องหน้าแมวอยู่ในกล่องอันนี้ก็อยู่ใน
กล่องอะไรอ่ะอันนี้อันนี้ก็อยู่ในกล่อง
เหมือนกันมีขี้ meme มาแล้วเห็นมืออาแมว
อยู่ตรงนี้แมวอยู่ในกล่อง
[เพลง]
โอเคอ่าแล้วตัวนี้อยู่ในกล่องไหมครับตอน
นี้อยู่ไหนแล้วอยู่ในกล่องอ๋ออ๋ออยู่ใน
กล่อง
5 แล้วตัวนี้นะครับตอนนี้อยู่ในกล่องไหม
แมวอยู่ในกล่อง
5 อยู่ในกล่องโอเคโอเค
แล้วตัวนี้นะครับตัวนี้อยู่ในเกาะห้องไหม
ตัวนี้หัวแมวหัวแมวอยู่ในกล่องขอเฉพาะหัว
แมวใช่มั้ยหัวตรงนี้ตรงนี้เป็นหัวหน้าหัว
ไว้อยู่ในกล่องแต่
นะครับตัวอยู่นอกกรอบตัวอยู่นอกตัวอยู่
นอกกล่อง
อยู่น้อ
R2 นอกกล่อง
[เพลง]
ให้หน้าเพราะว่ากล่องกล่องเล็กใช่ไหม
กล่องเล็กกล่องเล็กกล่องไม่ได้เข้าไม่ได้
ส่องเล็กนิดเดียว
ใจก็เลยอยู่นอกกล่องน้า
เฮเดี๋ยวเราไปภาพต่อไปภาพต่อไปครับ
อ้าอันนี้มีอะไรอยู่บ้างครับน้องเตรียม
เรียนถึง
ครับผู้ชายอ้าเฮียตีก็เห็นเห็นเด็กเด็ก
ผู้ชายว้าววหัว
หน้าซ้ายกับเด็กเพื่อให้เด็กตาย
มีอยู่ว่าเขายังเล็กตัวเล็กเราก็ได้ครับ
เด็กผู้ชายเป็นเด็กตัวเล็กห้าใช่ครับผู้
ชาย
หนีมีกลองอีกลอง R  R มีกล่องเหมือนกัน
นามิกล่องกล่องสีน้ำตาล
5 กล่องสีน้ำตาลแล้วเด็กผู้ชาย
กล่องสีน้ำตาลเตี้ยที่เห็นปล่องนิกล่อง
นี้มีอันนี้เป็นแท้ใช่ไหมครับเทปหน้าใช่
ครับเอ๊ะอันนี้
เปิด
ปิดกล่องไว้ใช่ไหม Siri ปิดกล่องฟ้ากล่อง
อะไรครับป้องอันนี้ปิดอยู่ติดอยู่ใช่ไหม
ครับ
ส่องปีบหน้าแล้วหน้าภาพต่อไปครับต่อไปภาพ
นี้ตอนนี้โอ๋เด็กเป็นไงครับ
ดีใจดีใจดีใจดีใจทำไมถึงดีใจครับว่า
[เพลง]
อ่ากล่องเปิด
เพราะว่ากล่องเปิดอ่ะเด็กก็เลยดีใจให้ใจ
อ้าลูกบอลอยู่อ๋ออ๋อมีลูกบอลอยู่ในกล่อง
ใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะเปิดออกมาอ่าได้ครับกล่อง
เปิดเปิดออกมา
ว้าวเปิดก่อนก็บอกโอ๊ยลูกบอลหน้ามีลูกบอล
เยอะเลยในกล่องใช่ค่ะมีลูกบอลเยอะเลย
มีสีชมพู
วุฒิบอลสีชมพู
ชมพู
หน้ามีสีชมพูสีอะไรสีฟ้าสีฟ้ามั้ยคือฟ้า
ค่ะครับ
หน้าแล้วมีสีอะไรอีกครับลูกบอลสีส้มอ้า
นี้นี้สีส้มว้าว
5วิสีอะไรครับ
เหลืองสีเหลืองอ่ะโอเค
อ่าแล้วลูกนี้ลูกมีสีอะไร
ลูกบอลสีแดง
สีแดงเย่
ว้าวมีลูกบอลหลายสีเลยอ่ะอาเฮียตีเห็นลูก
บอลสีสีนิซิเรียกสีอะไรครับ
ลูกบอลลูกบอลสีม่วง 5 อ่อนลูกบอลสีม่วง
ว้าว
สีฟ้าดีซ่อมฮ่าๆๆน้องเรียม I ใช่มั้ยน้อง
อีคำๆเพราะว่าอะไรครับเพราะว่าอากาศหนาว
ไหมอากาศหนาวหนาว
หนาวหน้าแต่พี่อาร์ตี้อากาศร้อนและเริ่ม
ร้อนและใส่เสื้อแขนสั้นใส่เสื้อแขนสั้น
อากาศสอนแล้วนะครับที่บ้านเรียมหนาวอ๋อ
อ๋อที่บ้านเรียมยังหนาวอยู่ว้าวหนาวอากาศ
หนาวดี
เอ 5 กล่องนี้ปิดใช่ไหมครับปิดอยู่
ส่วนกล่องนิเปิดจะเปิด
หน้า
เปิดเคๆเดี๋ยวเราไปดูรูปต่อไป
แล้ว
ครับอันนี้น่ามีอะไรบ้างรูปนี้ครับรูปตัว
นี้มีลิงอ๋ออ๋อลิงแล้วโอเคโอเคๆลิงลิงถือ
หรืออะไรอยู่ครับ
ลิงถือ
หนังสือหรืออ้อลิงถือหนังสือแล้วหนังสือ
นี้หนังสือนี้เป็นไงครับ
ปิดปิด 5 หนังสือปิดอยู่อ่ะโอเคอ่า Ring
คืนปิดหนังสือใช่ไหมครับใช่ค่ะอ้าวแล้ว
ลิงตัวนี้นะครับลิงตัวนี้ทำอะไรครับ
เปิดหนังสือ
อาขอพื้นที่เห็นหนังสืออยู่ตรงนี้เหมือน
กันแต่หนังสืออันนี้เปิดอยู่ใช่ไหมเปิด
หนังสือชัยห้องมีคนนี้ปี้ปลาอ่ะตัวนี้
เปิดก็เปิดหนังสือโอเคอ่ามีมิติแล้วก็มี
เปิดหน้าไปแคร์
หามีเปิดแล้วก็ปิดหน้าแล้วมีอีกรูปนึงรูป
นี้
เรียนเห็น
เด็กผู้หญิง
คนนี้เป็นเด็กผู้หญิงแล้ว
เด็กผู้หญิงแค่มีเด็กผู้หญิงออกแล้วอัน
นี้อะไรครับ
ทีวี
ทีวีโอเค
S อย่าตีเห็นเด็กผู้หญิงนี่ใช้มือใช้มือ
ก็กดมีกฎรอยตรงนี้ขวดหน้าครับกดกดทำไม
ครับกดเถิดมีเปิดเปิดทีวีอ้าวนี่ครับเปิด
ทีวี
ทีวีเปิดหน้าแล้วก็ก็ดูดูทีวีได้นะครับ
เนี่ยดูทีวีได้เพราะทีวีเปิดนะครับงานต่อ
มาแล้ว 5 ภาพนี้ครับครับนี้ตอนนี้เด็กผู้
หญิงกดเหมือนเดิมกดอีกแล้วน้ากดแต่ตอนนี้
ทีวีไม่มีไม่มีแล้วแบบนี้เรียกว่า
เรียกว่าปิดขอปิดทีวี
ใช่ค่ะปีกดปิดทีวี
อ้าโอเคอันนี้เปิดมาดูได้อันนี้นี้ปิดดู
ไม่ได้น้าเปิดที่ทำชี
ชอบผมผมเด็กผู้หญิงฮ่าๆๆใช่ผู้หญิงผมยาว
ใช่ไหมอ่าๆอ้าน้องเรียมกอง
แต่แนะนำอย่าให้ใช้สีทองเออผมยาวสีสีดำ
โอเค
ว้าวๆเดี๋ยววันนี้วันนี้เราเรียนคำว่า
อะไรกันบ้างครับ
วันนี้เราเรียนคำว่า
เค้าเปิดก่อนห้างเปิด
ปิดปิดอ่ะใช่ครับหน้าเปิดแล้วก็ปิดน่ะอัน
นี้อันนี้ก็เปิดเหมือนกันอ่ะและก็ปิดปิด
หน้าใช่ครับแล้วก็อ้ามีอะไรอีกครับอ้ามี
มีอ่านี้เป็น
นายไอใช้งับทั้งในส่วนนี้
นอก
นอกเคมีเปิดสิบปิดมีในมีนอกแล้วมีมีมี
อะไรครับ
โหมด P บนนะครับหน้ามีใต้ตาๆน้าโอเค
ว้าวบนตายอ้าวันนี้วันนี้เวลาวิชาของเรา
หมดแล้วแล้วแล้วอะเดี๋ยวคราวหน้ากลับมา
เจอกับเพียร์ตีเจอกับน้องเรียมในช่องของ
Friends  Thai กันใหม่นะครับไทยแล้วค่ะ
สำหรับ
อันนี้ก็ต้องลาไปก่อนค่ะขอบคุณค่ะพี่
อาร์ตี้สวัสดีครับน้องเรียมสวัสดีครับนัก
เรียนบ๊ายบายดีค่ะนักเรียนม